pour venir en aide à ces enfants
plusieurs approches une approche
j'allais dire local avec des ong on le
verra dans quelques instants que ce
tardieu qui est avec nous et puis les
approches plus mondial avec l'unicef
claire brisset est avec nous en
remercient directrice de l'information
de l'unicef
alors vous votre objectif final si je
puis dire c'est l'éradication complète
du travail des enfants dans le monde
à terme c'est bien entendu ce qu'il faut
obtenir il faut être réaliste aussi donc
déterminée plutôt deux stratégies de
type de stratégie la première c'est de
supprimer immédiatement tout ce qui est
absolument toxiques pour les enfants
c'est à dire tout ce qui les met en
danger tout ce qui est dangereux
la prostitution vous l'avez cité mais
d'autres travaux qui mettent leur vie en
danger - j'ai vu des ateliers où
l'expérience espérance de vie des
enfants et de 20 ans ça ça doit
s'arrêter immédiatement pour les autres
pour les autres il faut mettre au point
une stratégie d'éradication progressive
on se doute bien que 250 millions
d'enfants ne vont pas retourner à
l'école demain
mais si l'objectif alors qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire en attendant avec les enfants
qui sont déjà au travail
eh bien il faut faire entrer l'école
dans les lieux de travail c'est à dire
installer des classes partout où elle
peut dans les usines dans les ateliers
jean peu concrets membres essaient de
nous faire marrer au maroc
j'y suis allé la semaine dernière il ya
à fès par exemple une usine qui était
exemplaire non pas parce qu'elles
emploient des enfants mais parce qu'elle
a décidé à signer un accord avec le
représentant de l'unicef et aux
autorités locales et le patron de lusine
pour premièrement ne plus recruter
d'enfants de moins de 12 ans parce que
pour le moment il y en a qui ont
septembre huit ans deuxièmement ceux qui
sont là les scolariser trois heures par
jour et le patron de l' usine s'est
engagé à les payer de la même manière
c'est à dire à ne pas réduire leur
salaire déjà modeste très modeste parce
que ils seront scolarisés 3h penche
alors avec nos michel tardieu michel
tardieu bonjour vous êtes secrétaire
général de l'association enfants et
développement alors vous avez une option
qui paraissait un peu iconoclaste mais
qui s'en rapproche finalement de ce que
vient de dire madame brisset vous vous
dîtes surtout ne disons pas pas de
travail pour les enfants parce que ça
peut leur donner les situations bien
plus graves encore oui bonjour
effectivement nous avons une position
maintenant tout à fait proche de celle
2010 f qui consiste à dire que
il faut éradiquer absolument le travail
des enfants quand il s'agit de
l'exploitation de choses dangereuses et
toxiques et abusive nus qu'on ne peut
pas c'est un problème très complexe
qu'on ne peut pas traiter d'un seul d'un
seul trait il faut absolument arriver à
s'occuper de ses enfants à leur donner
la parole à écouter ce qu'ils ont à dire
que j'ai eu
oui est ce que vous dites dans quelque
sorte c'est que c'est facile vu d'europe
occidentale de dire que finalement il
faut que les enfants ne travaillent pas
mais vous en terrain vous dit ce serait
des décisions presque dangereuse
excessive que d'un seul coup d'enlever
les enfants des usines ou des ateliers
parce qu'ils se retrouvaient dans la rue
ils n'avaient vu ça sent du tfc des
exemples assez fréquent d'enfants qui
travaillent dans les ateliers où
effectivement ils sont exploités selon
nos conceptions européenne mais si on
les remet dans la rue parce que les
fabricants du bangladesh ou d'inde ou
d'ailleurs prennent peur d'un boycott de
produits dans lesquels les enfants
travaillent
il le médecin il mettait enfants dans la
rue les remettent au chômage et à ce
moment là les enfants tombent dans des
conditions d'exploitation bien pires qui
vont de l'excitation sexuelle à
l'exploitation au travail dans des
conditions bien plus horrible que celle
qu'ils avaient précédemment
merci monsieur tardieu nous voulions
souligner cela c'est une position qui me
choque pas à l'abri c'est finalement
vous êtes sur la même longueur d'onde
mais il était important de dire que ça
paraît facile d'ici de dire il ne faut
pas que les enfants travaillent mais il
faut voir où ils risquent de tomber
également ils savent où en est
consciente
mais de toute façon nous l'avons vu nous
mêmes au bangladesh plusieurs dizaines
de milliers d'enfants sont retrouvés
dans la rue quand il ya eu la
proposition d'un sénateur américain
pendante à abolir l'entrée sur les
territoires des états unis ce qui était
fabriqué fabriqués par des enfants
c'est vrai que le risque existe mais ce
qui est très important c'est de ne pas
perdre le cap et le cap c'est
l'éradication à terme et pour ça il ya
un instrument c'est l'école merci alors
je vais présenter votre livre claire
brisset donc dans la collection opinion
un monde qui dévore ses enfants donc
chez liana levi vous expliquez fort bien
de tout ce que vous venez de résumer
dans votre journal merci madame